well now it's time for a pick from the  little yellow book that's our curated  list of stuff i love that i always want  to share with you we refresh it every  single week on our website and today's  pick is a greeting card that you can  grow  in the ground  thoughtful human cards i love these so  much so they're plantable they have  seeds in them and they come  one for every occasion i really like  this one we're all rooting for you it's  very like sporty and then when you're  done you crumple it or cut it up and you  stick it in some soil  and not only is it zero waste but then  you can actually cultivate a little life  out of it that is so cute i know i  wonder if it's this would be great too  for like a wedding invite or something  yeah you could invite someone on on to  your wedding on yeah and then they could  stick it somewhere and grow something  out of it well they can stick that text  somewhere  [Music]  you